hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
this is a quick and brief update as to
what's going on in the property market
right now
what's going to happen what are people
doing what are the government doing what
are the changes that are going on
so if you enjoy my channel please do me
a massive favor and smash the like
button
also there's a lot of people talking a
lot of nonsense around property industry
there's lots of scare-mongering fake
news around the property market
so it's really important you hit the
like button because then this video will
get picked up with more people
which means that more people be able to
educate themselves properly and
understand what really is going
on also if you're not subscribed do me a
massive favor subscribe
turn the notification bell on so you
don't miss my future videos because
listen
every time there's an update sometimes
they don't
the media and the press don't talk about
the things that are actually really need
to be talked about
and they talk about a lot of sideline
issues because there's always an agenda
let me give you an example
when section 24 came in the media were
talking about the tax changes with
section 24
and how bad it was going to be but what
they didn't mention
was that they changed the rules whereby
they said this doesn't apply for
companies oh by the way
by the way anyone can set up a virgin
company become a guarantor of the
company and then section 24 doesn't
apply
that wasn't mentioned anywhere in the
media so it's really important to
get your information from the right
sources i have written a full article
which you can find in the description
whereby you'll be able to see more
information but i'll give you a brief
overview right now
in this youtube video so do subscribe do
like let's get started so firstly
it's really important to follow the
money who are the big
organizations with the most amounts of
money and what are they investing in
what are they doing with their money
and right now i mean john lewis
the massive company have just announced
that they're going to be investing in
and building 10 000
homes in the united kingdom
so they're a massive player wanting to
build properties right now
so when you hear people saying oh it's a
bad time to get into property it's a bad
time to invest
why don't you go and tell john lewis
that because clearly john lewis don't
think so
lloyd's bank i've mentioned this before
they've now put forward their business
plan
and announced quietly um what they're
planning to do and it's huge
lloyd's bank are going to become an
absolute massive landlord here in the uk
and they've never been aggressively
wanting to buy residential properties in
the uk
more than they are doing right now so
again follow the money
not just lloyd's bank in the uk there's
also banks as far as australia
a a large australian bank have just
announced that they're going to be
pumping money
into residential property in the uk
now what does that mean for you does
that mean that properties are going to
rise they're going to fall
what it means is that the large
companies with lots of wealth if they
think
that residential uk property is a safe
bet
then it's probably a good sign that it
is too many people are like
wondering when's the perfect time you
know should i just wait a little bit
more properties to go up or
should i wait for them to crash or shall
i wait wait wait wait well the rich
large companies aren't doing that
they're jumping in now so it just
is an indication that property in the uk
is probably a safe bet
i've been saying this for years we've
got a shortage of houses we've got an
overpopulation of people
and you know i've been saying this for
years but it's not just me
it's also other large companies so what
else is going on in the news
well also in august the first of august
they are officially bringing in new
changes
that will make it much easier to convert
commercial properties
to residential properties again this is
huge
there's so many shops offices warehouses
that are going out of business there's
loads of commercial properties
and the value of these commercial
properties is dropping the value of
residential properties is rising so
how do the rich people make their money
in real estate who makes up the rules
the rich people if you look at the mps
a quarter of them are making money in
property themselves
i believe that everybody should be able
to get a slice of the pie
and the great news is you can now buy an
office you don't have to buy it with
your money
but you can buy an office and you can
convert it into a house without having
to get planning permission in many cases
now there are
a few hoops you need to jump through you
do need to put forward your intention
and it's not totally
uh it's not a case of you can just do it
without getting any permission
but it's simpler than it's ever been and
in the article below i talk in more
details
about what that looks like so check out
the article i've put it i've put a link
in the description
um in other news the government are
putting an extra tax on property
developers
and again everyone's freaking out about
this oh man they're charging property
developers and the reason the government
are doing it is because they're saying
they want some of
some money back to put towards some of
the things that they've had to be
spending a lot of money on as a result
of the lockdown and the pandemic
the good news is i can confirm
tax that they're going to be charging
property developers is only going to be
for property developers making a
profit of 25
million pounds a year so this isn't
going to affect
me it isn't going to affect you probably
unless you happen to be a
you know a very very big property
development company like taylor wimpey
or someone like that
it's probably not going to affect you
but it does mean that the government are
hopeful and optimistic
about where the economy is going about
where the property market's going so i'm
really excited i hope you are too
if you want more tips and information
like this then drop a comment below let
me know what you want me to talk about
what you want me to research
what you want me to share don't forget
to read the article below if you want to
receive
training property investment training i
am running some free courses
upcoming again i'll leave a link in the
description about that
i hope you found this video helpful
share it around with your property
investment friends
hit the like button and i'll see you
guys in the next video